[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend und gute nachrichten
wenigstens auf papier die
weltklimakonferenz hat einigungen
erzielt bei denen man sich allerdings
schon ein bisschen wundert dass sie
nicht schon längst gelten so henning
fritz leicht zu ernten die früchte der
klimadiplomatie die eigentlich schon
lang im korb hätten sein müssen
methangase bis zu 80 mal schlimmer als
klimagas als co2 sollen endlich
systematisch reduziert werden und besser
noch mehr als 100 nationen auch die mit
den größten wäldern von russland bis
brasilien
verpflichten sich zu ihrem schutz halt
auf papier vielleicht zu schön um wahr
zu werden und trotzdem für einen
positiven impuls reicht's für die
operation weltklima braucht es mehr
diana zimmermann berichtet aus glasgow
bäume fällen ist ganz leicht auch da wo
es verboten ist ein mann eine kettensäge
und schon wieder ein co2 vernichter
weniger
viele menschen haben mehr angst vor dem
hunger als vor dem klimawandel oder dem
gesetz jede minute geht weltweit eine
weite fläche in der größe von 27
fußballfeldern verloren die erste große
vereinbarung die auf der klimakonferenz
in glasgow getroffen wurde ist eine
allianz zur rettung des waldes mehr als
100 staaten haben sich dazu verpflichtet
die entscheidung bis 2030 zu stoppen und
eine wende einzuleiten
in den nationen der unterzeichnenden
gegen 85 prozent der wälder der erde
erstmals machen auch china und brasilien
mit das ist erfreulich zu sehen auf der
anderen seite gerade die dritten ganz
viel indem sie andere methoden verwenden
und das nur auf dem papier dann wälder
schutz gemacht wird dort gilt es ganz
genau hinzuschauen
tatsächlich gab es ein ähnliches
abkommen schon vor sieben jahren daraus
wurde weitgehend ignoriert eine gefahr
die immer besteht auch bei der
bekämpfung des neben kohlendioxid
zweiten hauptschuldigen am klimawandel
dem methan seine konzentration in der
atmosphäre hat sich in den letzten 200
jahren durch schiefergas
anbau und die viehzucht verdoppelt rund
80 staaten wollen nun den ausstoß des
treibhausgases in den nächsten zehn
jahren um 30 prozent reduzieren ganz
vorne dabei die usa und die eu
die haft wir müssen den ausstoß von
treibhausgasen schnell reduzieren und
methan kann man schnell reduzieren wenn
wir das tun werden wir den klimawandel
sofort verlangsamen doing what lies
lowdown climate change allerdings
spielen die große verschmutzer china
russland und indien hier nicht mit der
russische und chinesische präsident sind
gar nicht erst nach glasgow gekommen
als wesentliches für einen großen fehler
des chinas präsident nicht gekommen ist
der rest der welt schaut gen china und
fragt sich welchen mehrwert leisten sie
sie haben an einfluss verloren in der
welt und hierbei kommt nun dasselbe geht
meiner ansicht nach für russland
doch der einfluss der beiden riesen
staaten auf das klima ist weiterhin groß
und kooperation mit ihnen wichtig sie
den park nicht lang sein aber die
chinesische delegation diskutiert
natürlich mit und auch jeder weiß was
die stunde geschlagen hat drängen lassen
von den westlichen industrienationen
aber will es sich nicht die staats und
regierungschefs reisen nun ab zum
resümee des us-präsidenten gehörte auch
dass glasgow nur der auftakt sein für
ein jahrzehnt dem es gelingen müsse die
erderwärmung aufzuhalten
elf tage lang werden verhandlungsführer
delegierte und aktivisten nun versuchen
in kleinen schritten einen großen für
die welt zu tun
seltsam unberührt vom weltgeschehen
jedenfalls seit dem wahlausgang ziemlich
irrelevant dafür beschäftigt sich
derweil die einstige kanzlerpartei cdu
mit sich selbst sie muss sich um
organisieren auf rekonvaleszenz und
opposition seit heute weiß sie wie sie
eine neue führung wählen will aber
natürlich noch nicht welche nachdem das
andere schief gegangen ist soll diesmal
die basis den weg zum ergebnis planen
für all die männer aus nrw die wollen
beginnt damit die phase in der man vor
allem keine öffentlichen fehler machen
sollte und trotzdem spricht nach mathis
feldhoff bericht norbert röttgen mit uns
macht nicht jeder
es wirkt immer noch ziemlich
verschwommen was sich die cdu da
vorgenommen hat heute hat man sich auf
einen zeitplan eine art zeitstrahl
geeinigt und schon dabei festgestellt
dass nicht alle wünsche die die partei
derzeit so hat unter einen hut passen
die einen sagen möglichst breite
mitglieder beteiligen und die anderen
sagen das muss aber schnell gehen
potenziell schließen sich die beiden
ziele aus
fünfeinhalb stunden hat die cdu-führung
heute über die befragung ihrer
mitglieder diskutiert fünfeinhalb
stunden in denen am ende ein parteitag
am 21
januar steht am samstag beginnt die
erste phase die bewerbungsphase mögliche
kandidaten verlassen heute das adenauer
haus ziemlich zugeknöpft auch wenn das
partei und land ziemlich ratlos
zurücklässt für den noch vorsitzenden
einer art zwischenerfolg
es ist bis zum heutigen tag gelungen
dass es noch keine bewerbungen gibt dass
wir mit allen im gespräch sind wo die
ersten bewerbungen sollten dann ein
treffen ab dem kommenden samstag
subtiler druck auf die unerklärten
bewerber friedrich merz sondiert ob er
das duo jens spahn und carsten lindemann
in seine mannschaft ziehen kann das
überwinden persönliche abneigungen
zwischen sparen und märz wäre eine
voraussetzung
norbert röttgen dem eine gewisse
beliebtheit zugeschrieben wird und
fraktionschef ralph brinkhaus könnte das
ins abseits befördern ich persönlich
glaube es kommt jetzt weniger darauf an
was sind die einzelinteressen einer
einzigen person sondern es muss ein team
gefunden werden dass die partei bereit
ist zu führen dieser schwierigen lage
und ich bin der festen überzeugung dass
ich nur der durchsetzen wird der auf
jeden fall in form eines teams ins
rennen geht auch andere namen werden
gehandelt mike mohring etwa als
generalsekretär im team erzählt jung und
ostdeutsche sein nachteil er ist keine
frau
das ist eine der bitteren wahrheiten in
der cdu sowohl in der aktuellen
parteiführung und möglicherweise auch in
der künftigen haben frauen derzeit keine
wirklich führende rolle
stattdessen macht sich armin laschet
gedanken darüber ob der neue cdu
vorsitzende
trotz mitgliederbeteiligung wirklich die
ganze partei repräsentiert nicht dass es
seinem nachfolger so geht wie ihm selbst
wir brauchen ein klima in dem der oder
die die dann gewählt ist die
unterstützung aller anderen hat eine
hürde dafür hat laschet heute schon mal
elegant beseitigt ein quorum also eine
mindestbeteiligung an der
mitgliederbefragung hat er verhindert
wie stehe denn die partei da kann man
das nicht schaffe
schönen guten abend nach berlin herr
röttgen guten abend herr kleber da war
jetzt dauernd von teams die rede wenn es
um die führung der partei geht sind sie
bereit sich einem team einzuordnen ja
selbstverständlich ich habe ja zum
beispiel auch im januar kandidiert bin
dort unterlegt mit einem respektablen
ergebnissen habe gesagt ich akzeptiere
selbstverständlich als demokrat dieses
ergebnis und ich bin seither mitglied
des parteipräsidiums und arbeite mit und
war im wahlkampf viel unterwegs ja wir
brauchen eine mannschaft es geht gar
nicht ohne mannschaft die mannschaft
wird aber gewählt und auch ausgewählt
die mannschaft ist das präsidium der
bundesvorstand und wir brauchen sogar
mannschaftsgeist das kann nicht das werk
eines erlöser seien auf den alle warten
sondern das kann nur als
gemeinschaftswerk gelingen und ich
möchte gern teil dieses
gemeinschaftswerk seien aber doch nicht
in einer untergeordneten position sie
stellen sich schon vor der teamleader zu
sein denn das wurde ja heute auch klar
gestellt eine doppelspitze soll es nicht
geben ein mensch nach gegenwärtiger lage
ein mann soll die partei führen in der
rolle sehen sie sich doch oder
das ist ja verabredet worden dass es
jetzt einen festen zeitplan gibt und
auch dafür dass es vorschläge
nominierungen oder auch erklärungen zur
kandidatur gibt das läuft ab dem
nächsten samstag zehn tage lang das ist
aber von ihnen schon passiert viele von
uns journalisten mindestens haben sie
heute gestern morgen im deutschlandfunk
gehört dann sehr erklärt es muss ein
mann aus der mitte sein das ist
offensichtlich in der cdu nicht jeder
und zweitens sie verkörpern die mit wenn
das keine bewerbung ist weiß ich nicht
wie eine bewerbung aussieht müssen sie
dann formblatt noch unterschreiben
das ist meine vorstellung von der
führung wie die partei aussehen muss und
wie sie geführt werden muss wir sind
eine breite partei wir müssen uns ja
gerade wieder als volkspartei neu
begründen und zwar von der idee her
politisch aber auch gesellschaftlich und
organisatorisch es gibt auch flügel
unterschiedliche richtungen aber die cdu
darf selber keine richtungs partei
werden wir sind es nicht wir sind partei
der mitte das heißt es kann links und
recht etwas geben aber das zentrum das
muss die mitte sein das muss eine
moderne mitte für unsere moderne
gesellschaft sein das ist meine
vorstellung von der führung der partei
ihre vorstellung von der führung der
partei durch die mitte würde die auch
durch einen vorsitzenden märz zum
beispiel verkörpert ich habe mich und
werde mich nicht über andere personen
äußern ich kenne friedrich merz seit
jahrzehnten ich schätze ihn ich glaube
wir schätzen uns er ist teil der partei
aber ich habe nur ausgedrückt was wie
ich mir die cdu vorstellen und es gibt
unterschiedliche richtungen das ist
bekannt es gibt cds gibt die
mittelstands-union es gibt
konservativere liberalere das zentrum
muss die moderne mitte sein das ist
unverrückbar nur dort können wir
gewinnen das sind wir als cdu ideell und
da findet der gesellschaftliche kampf um
die mehrheit statt wenn wir das
verschieben würden denn wer eine rechts
verschiebung erleben würden dann würden
wir den anderen parteien spd grüne fdp
freien raum lassen sich zu etablieren
und uns zu verdrängen im moment
präsentiert sich diese mitte und
sämtliche flügel in den gesichtern von
männern wenn es in der union eine frau
der mitte mit führungsposition gibt und
es ist ja fast ausgeschlossen dass es
die nicht gibt dann müssten sie als team
führer eigentlich mit ihrer zurzeit
verhandlungen führen tun sie das also
ich finde es etwas paternalistisch zu
sagen jetzt wer ist denn die frau jeder
kann und jede kann kandidieren
wir hatten 20 jahren mit angela merkel
eine weibliche parteivorsitzende ihr ist
eine frau als parteivorsitzende gefolgt
in der cdu kann jede und jeder jedes amt
bekommen aber sie haben völlig recht
meine vorstellung ist dass es völlig
ausgeschlossen ist dass in den
verbliebenen spitzenämtern der
opposition parteivorsitzender
fraktionsvorsitzender generalsekretär
diese spitze allein mendig wäre das
passt nicht zu einer volkspartei das
wäre nicht moderne mitte nun hat er die
cdu wenig erfahrung und die wenige ist
sehr schlecht mit mitgliederbefragungen
für die führungsposition in baden
württemberg wo das probiert 2004 schavan
gegen oettinger eine spaltung
katastrophe von der sich die partei bis
heute nicht erholt hat wie wollen sie
mit dem verfahren dass sie jetzt gewählt
haben für die führungsentscheidung
diese katastrophe vermeiden also erstens
halte ich es für ein wirkliches gerücht
und für in der sache falsch dass die
mitgliederbefragung damals eine spaltung
herbeigeführt hat die differenz die es
gab gab es vorher sie ist nicht durch
die befragung beteiligung der mitglieder
herbeigeführt worden sie ist aber auch
durch die befragung der mitglieder dann
nicht zur zufriedenheit aller erledigt
worden und das problem das ist richtig
und darum würde ich auch
mitgliederbefragungen nicht als 1 1 ein
instrument der befriedung beschreiben es
ist ein instrument der partizipation
dass wir jetzt diese mitglieder befragen
bekommen das drückt aus wie zieht es
eigentlich eine repräsentative partei
aber es drückt aus wir haben eine
besondere lage das war eine zäsur diese
bundestagswahl nicht nur opposition
sondern wir kommen wenn das wenn das so
bliebe wie das ergebnis war wären wir
nicht mehr volkspartei und die
mitglieder drücken aus wir brauchen
einen neuanfang und wir wollen teil
dieses neuanfangs sein darum geht es wir
sind auch nicht gespalten aber wir
müssen uns neu begründen wir müssen uns
neu gesellschaftlich verankern wir haben
das diskutieren unterlassen auch die
dass wir uns mit den modernen themen
hinreichend beschäftigt haben da ist
jetzt viel arbeit zu tun und die
mitglieder wollen mitmachen das ist es
aber auch nicht mehr und das interview
jetzt war ein baustein dafür danke für
das gespräch und einen schönen abend
hörten ich danke ihnen sehr
und hier geht es weiter mit nachrichten
aus der welt in afghanistans hauptstadt
kabul sind bei einem angriff auf das
militär-krankenhaus mindestens zwölf
menschen getötet worden weitere wurden
verletzt ein selbstmordattentäter hatte
sich laut augenzeugen am eingangstor in
die luft gesprengt danach kam es zu
gefechten mit sicherheitskräften
ein sprecher der taliban machte die mit
ihnen verfeindeten terrorgruppe
islamischer staat für den anschlag
verantwortlich
den regionalen us ableger werden seit
der machtübernahme der taliban
zahlreiche angriffe zugeschrieben
es war auch ein sympathisant des die es
der heute vor einem jahr in wien einen
terrorangriff verübte mit mehreren
gedenkfeier wurde an die opfer erinnert
im beisein zahlreicher angehöriger ein
kranz niedergelegt in der wiener
ruprechtskirche gedachte österreichs
staatsspitze der opfer und
hinterbliebenen
am abend des zweiten november hatte ein
österreicher in einem belebten wiener
ausgehviertel vier menschen erschossen
darunter eine deutsche studentin wenige
minuten nach beginn der attacke wurde
der angreifer durch schüsse der polizei
getötet
die rund 21 millionen rentnerinnen und
rentner in deutschland können sich auf
eine deutliche erhöhung ihrer bezüge
einstellen nach einer offiziellen
schätzung sollen laut deutscher
presseagentur die renten im kommenden
juli in westdeutschland um 5,2 prozent
und im osten um 5,9 prozent steigen
wegen corona gab es in diesem jahr im
westen eine nullrunde im osten ein
kleines plus von gut 0,7 prozent
angesichts steigender infektionszahlen
verschärft sachsen die schutzmaßnahmen
die landesregierung in dresden will die
2g regel für etwa gastronomie und
fußballstadien prüfen und das wird wohl
ab montag so sein dass dann nur noch
geimpfte und genesene diese besuchen
dürfen und in baden württemberg tritt
morgen die korona warnstufe in kraft die
zahl der kurve 19 patienten auf
intensivstationen
ist den zweiten tag in folge über den
wert von 250 gestiegen damit brauchen
ungeimpfte im südwesten nun einen
pcr-test zum beispiel für den
restaurantbesuch
auf ungeimpfte kommen auch in anderen
ländern verschärfte test pflichten zu in
brandenburg rheinland pfalz und in
mecklenburg vorpommern muss sich
ungeimpfte pflege und klinikpersonal
künftig täglich testen bundesweit
meldete das robert koch-institut binnen
24 stunden zehn
1813 neuinfektionen das sind 340 mehr
als vor einer woche die sieben tage
incidents sinkt im vergleich zu gestern
leicht auf
153,7 möglicherweise sind die zahlen
aber nicht vollständig übermittelt weil
gestern in fünf bundesländern feiertag
war
eindeutig gegen den trend dieser zahlen
und gegen grassierende befürchtungen hat
das bevölkerungsreichste bundesland
heute die masken pflicht am sitzplatz in
schulen aufgehoben während bayern daran
denkt sie morgen wieder einzuführen
hendrik wüst der neue ministerpräsident
von nrw verkündete das motto so viel
schutz wie nötig so viel freiheit wie
möglich das klingt gut beantwortet aber
nicht die entscheidende frage was ist
denn nötig und was möglich ist
wiederholt diese frage nur in schulen
ist das besonders heikel weil es für
kinder unter zwölf jahren ja noch keinen
impfschutz gibt das heißt die geben mit
der maske gleich den einzigen schutz ab
den sie haben und auch wenn schilder
selten schwer erkranken können sie viren
leicht von einer familie in eine andere
tragen das will schon gut überlegt sein
nrw hat entschieden berichtet peter
böhme
daumen hoch oder daumen runter
kleine umfrage durch die lehrerin heute
in dieser fünften klasse der leibniz
gesamtschule in duisburg ab heute im
unterricht am platz keine masken pflicht
mehr bei den kleineren finden viele also
ich finde das schon schöne weiche ich
kriege der luft und mit der brille war
es auch schon ein bisschen doof es ist
halt jetzt besser mit wenn man noch die
fenster aufmacht noch ein bisschen mehr
frische luft kommt auch
ältere schüler dagegen sind skeptischer
angesichts der auch in
nordrhein-westfalen steigenden instanzen
aktuell hat das einfach für falsch da
einfach die instanz immer wieder steigt
und wie auch in der schule
positive fälle haben und deswegen will
ich das aktuell noch zu verfrüht die
masken pflicht im unterricht umstritten
wie so vieles in der korona krise an der
duisburger schule hatten sie in den
letzten monaten im schnitt zwei fälle
pro woche also eine stabile lage und
darauf verweist auch die schulministerin
die letzten ergebnisse haben gezeigt
dass wir nach wie vor keine ausbrüche an
unseren schulen haben 0,1 prozent der am
schulleben beteiligten sind infiziert
und das ist jetzt ein verantwortbarer
schritt den wir gehen können andere
bundesländer wie das saarland berlin
oder bayern haben die masken pflicht
schon länger aufgeweicht sie verweisen
bisher darauf dass die instanzen bei
schülern dem allgemeinen trend folgten
es also seitdem keine spezielle dynamik
gäbe der virologe martin stürmer hält
die konsequente masken pflicht aber
weiterhin für wichtig stichwort longo
wird meiner meinung nach ist noch nicht
abschließend geklärt wie das mit longo
wird bei den kindern und jugendlichen
aussieht ich möchte vermeiden dass wir
uns in fünf jahren plötzlich lauter
kranke kinder vor uns haben die an
spätfolgen der krone infektionen leyen
die wir in der aktuellen phase nicht
ziehen und deswegen bin ich jetzt eher
vorsichtige als das risiko eingehen zu
wollen
der schulleiter in duisburg sagt zur
neuregelung erst mal abwarten wie es
läuft er hat aber auch vier kollegen mit
vorerkrankungen die sind besorgt in
deren fall kann er nur an die schüler
appellieren haben schreiben fertig
gemacht für die schülerinnen und schüler
dieser gruppen in denen die solidarität
und den team spirit appelliere und für
diese für kollege kollegen die erwartung
äußere dass in den unterrichten weiter
die masken getragen werden rücksicht
stadt anordnung in nrw wird nun aber
auch die quarantäne regelung wieder
verschärft für den direkten sitznachbarn
eines erkrankten kindes gilt quarantäne
ausnahme geimpft oder genießen ohne
symptome die aufweichung der masken
pflicht hat also ihren preis
an den finanzmärkten schaut man auf gute
unternehmensnachrichten so hat trotz
corona und materialengpässen zum
beispiel die weltgrößte
containerreederei maersk ihren gewinn
verfünffacht frank bethmann der logistik
konzern profitiert natürlich von den
pandemie folgen ja das ist so mehr
hasste und andere reedereien haben
zuletzt sagenhaft verdient nach dem jahr
2020 in der globalen flaute stecken der
dänische logistik anspricht aber
inzwischen ganz offen von rekordzahlen
noch nie habe man in einem einzigen
quartal soviel geld erwirtschaftet
5,45 milliarden dollar waren es im
dritten quartal bereits davor im zweiten
brachte ist die reederei auf 3,7
milliarden dollar schon damals im sommer
war das mehr als merkel
gesamten jahr 2020 an gewinn gemacht
hatte erst corona anschließend haben die
staus vor wichtigen meeresenge und
vorhäfen die ungleichverteilung von
containern weltweit noch massiv
verstärkt wurden der folge container
fehlten die nachfrage aber nach waren
und gütern hoch war stiegen die
frachtkosten teilweise ins unermessliche
auf der strecke shanghai hamburg wurden
bis zu 14.000 dollar pro container
gezahlt das ist nicht immer so weiter
geht wissen die reedereien nur zu genau
es ist noch nicht lange her da steckten
die gleichen konzerne mittendrin in
einer ausgewachsenen krise solch starke
schwankungen seien schlecht fürs
geschäft hört man es dann auch aus der
vorstands etage des deutschen rivalen
das mit den schwankungen kennen sie hier
an der börse auch der zeit der dax aber
weiter im vorwärtsgang heute ein plus
von fast 150 punkten und gedanken nach
frankfurt
ein ergebnis aus der
fußball-champions-league vom abend der
vfl wolfsburg hat unter neu trainer
florian kufeld seinen gruppenspiel gegen
rb salzburg mit 2 1 gewonnen mit nun
fünf punkten rücken die wolfsburger in
der champions league gruppe g vorerst
auf den zweiten platz vor auf der
kanaren insel la palma ist infolge des
vulkanausbruchs erneut der flugverkehr
eingestellt worden zudem seien 22
schulen geschlossen worden weil die
konzentration von schwefeldioxid in der
luft an einigen stellen der insel zu
hoch sei teilten lokale behörden mit
seit dem beginn des vulkanausbruchs
mitte september sind mehr als 2700
gebäude zerstört oder beschädigt worden
noch immer können auch experten nicht
einschätzen wann der ausbruch enden wird
irgendwann dämmert wohl den meisten mal
der gedanke dass es doch schön sein
könnte seine erlebnisse seine
berührendsten und wildesten augenblicke
irgendwie festzuhalten bei den meisten
ist solche erkenntnis eine
alterserscheinung und damit meist
eindeutig zu spät sir paul mccartney hat
natürlich kein tagebuch geschrieben sein
leben hätte da auch kaum reingepasst der
erfolgreichste und jedenfalls einer der
produktivsten songwriter die jemals
lebte hat in fast 65 jahren seit seinem
ersten song seine liedertexte
festgehalten und siehe da auch so kann
man eine eigene biografie schreiben
jedenfalls als beatle paul mccartney es
ist ein gewaltiges werk geworden kam
heute raus und das schadet dem werk gar
nichts das man bei fast jeder zeile das
lied dahinter im geiste mitsingt barbara
lueg hat sich davon einfangen lassen
es ist eine kühle nach damals nebel
zieht durch die straßen von
liverpool liegt im bett und schläft
unruhig als ihm plötzlich seine
verstorbene mutter mary im traum
erschienen
ist ein magischer moment sie schien zu
spüren dass ich mit mir kämpfte und dann
sagte sie es wird alles gut
am nächsten morgen setzt er sich sofort
ans klavier und schreibt einen der
größten songs der musikgeschichte
[Musik]
was heute weltweit erscheint ist voll
solcher geschichten eine schatzkammer in
zwei bänden
was ich habe erzählt paul in seinem
vorwort sind meine songs
und so öffnet er hier sein innerstes für
die welt im spiegel seiner lieder
nie gezeigte fotos gedanken notizen
umstände die ihn inspirierten und
verfolgten sie fragen immer was ist die
formel für hits wir haben geantwortet
dass wir sie hoffentlich nie finden
werden
über fünf jahre vertraut der heute
79-jährige diesem buchprojekt in langen
interviews sein ganzes leben an
es sind die geschichten hinter den songs
die so anrührend melodiebögen die sich
plötzlich anders anfühlen die zahlen die
neuem licht erscheinen es sind
geschichten wie diese
als sich john lennon und seine erste
frau cynthia scheiden lassen besucht
paul ihren sohn julien um ihn zu trösten
auf der fahrt kommt paul eine idee
ich dachte an julien und diese zeilen
kamen sondern ages nimmt es nicht so
schwer es wird alles gut ich wollte ihn
unterstützen
[Musik]
aus sulz wird später tot
es ist ein stück zeit und
musikgeschichte das heute an die
öffentlichkeit kommt aber vor allem sein
ganz persönliches vermischten
was das wichtigste für ihn in jedem
meine kinder meine frau meine familie
das ist am ende das wichtigste
[Musik]
wen wundert es da noch dass diese
botschaft in einem welthit links
verewigt ist
toll und fast ewig bob dylan hat so
ähnlich den literatur nobelpreis
gewonnen sein prachtband aus texten war
allerdings dicker als die beiden bände
von mccartney zusammen
die anstalt für mich das intelligenteste
und beste kabarett auf deutschen
bildschirmen widmet sich gleich dem
artensterben mit großer lust an
verkleidung und in topbesetzung das land
versprochen und um 0.45 meldet sich nah
sein möchte mir mit unserem
heute-journal update bis morgen
[Musik]
ein schöne gute und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter eindringlich sind die appelle
bei der cop 26 und dass die staaten
liefern müssen erinnern sie sich noch an
das montreal protokoll zum verbot ozon
schädlicher stoffe wie zb fckw das war
soweit erfolgreich allerdings sind noch
immer 90 prozent dieser ozonkiller im
vergleich zum jahr 2000 in der luft eine
aktuelle studie zeigt mit zunehmender
erhitzung der erde wird die stratosphäre
über der arktis im winter kälter dabei
entstehen ozonkiller und die bauen im
frühjahr wenn die sonne stärker wird
ozon ab ein ozonloch entsteht das ganze
spielt sich um den polarwirbel ab wenn
sich dieser aber richtung europa
verlagert bekommen wir mehr von diesen
schädlichen uv strahlen ab so wird durch
die erhitzung das ziel des montreal
protokolls die ozonschicht zu schützen
gemindert ein zusätzliches problem der
globalen klimakrise
wir schauen in die nacht so und da wird
es in der mitte deutschlands regen geben
und nach nordwesten das lässt aber nach
von frankreich her kommt neuer regen auf
und das bei tiefsten temperaturen an den
alpen von minus 1 grad leichter frost
und 6 grad zb an der nordsee morgen im
tagesverlauf gibt es relativ viele
wolken im südwesten und teilte auch
länger andauernden regen nach osten hin
zeigt sich häufiger die sonne bei
temperaturen von sechs grad in der eifel
und 12 grad im osten deutschlands und
die nächsten tage am donnerstag ist es
noch sehr durchwachsen bei fünf bis zehn
grad danach wird es etwas kühler aber
sonnigen schöner abend